a funeral is being held for a
two-year-old Palestinian boy killed by
Israeli forces in the occupied West Bank
Muhammad hate them Tamimi and his father
were hit by Israeli fire on Thursday
while sitting in a car it happened
during an Israeli raid on the village of
Nabi Salah near Ramallah Villa Marx
joins us live from Nabi salawa that
funeral is being held and Willam
explained to us just how it came to be
that a toddler was shot dead
well according to the family of two and
a half year old Mohamed El Tamimi his
father and he were getting into a
vehicle at the house not far from where
we are now very close to an Israeli
military checkpoint at the entrance to
this Village and after one shot had been
heard by the mother of Muhammad the
father tried to move his car away from
the checkpoint it had been damaged in
the past and he was concerned about
damage once again in ensuing gunfire
that seemed to alert the Israeli
soldiers at the checkpoint to his
presence when he turned on the Lights of
the car and the car was then shredded
with a large number of bullets that left
him the father hyphen injured into his
left shoulder and a bullet lodged in the
brain of two and a half year old
Muhammad he was taken to a hospital by a
helicopter in Jerusalem and
unfortunately two days later died of
those injuries and it's such a
distressing story but not perhaps an
uncommon one to people that are in the
occupied West Bank what reaction are we
seeing from the family and Palestinians
widely in the community
well he's certainly not the first
Palestine in the West Bank to be killed
this year dozens have already been
involving clashes with Israeli military
forces he's certainly the youngest
though at just two and a half this
community here is in anguish the mother
has described him in a Facebook post
after he died as a martyr the father
incredibly angry and upset about what's
happened the mother telling us just in
the last couple of hours that she's
going to pursue legal remedies with the
Israeli authorities to try and determine
who was responsible in the exact
circumstances of the child's death the
Israeli military have said that they
have apologized they are sorry for the
non-intentional death of non-combatants
in this incident but the Palestinian
authorities saying they don't trust an
internal investigation the Israelis are
carrying out to get to the truth of this
situation
okay Villa Mark's joining us that from
the funeral site for that two-year-old
Palestinian boy thanks very much villain